essa sou eu quando tinha 15 anos
é muito interessante porque essa foto
foi tirada apenas duas semanas antes do
acidente
eu não tinha 15 anos ainda eu ia fazer
15 anos
então foi assim 15 anos 13 anos
vou namorar vou casar ou ter filhos
ele não vai gostar de mim porque eu
tenho uma espinha né
e aí nessa idade duas semanas após essa
foto
eu sofri um acidente ele não vai gostar
de mim porque eu não tenho uma perna
como é que alguém vai gostar de mim
porque eu não eu não tendo uma perna
eu não usava próteses não faz apenas
dois anos que eu estou usando próteses e
usava muletas e todos esses medos nessa
fase de 15 anos passou pela minha cabeça
e agora veio o pensamento se eu me casar
se eu tiver filhos o que ele vai sentir
só quem vai sentir vergonha de mim
quando foi à escola só que ele vai
querer esconder que eu sou mãe dele né
isso é possível porque sinceramente a
minha mãe é uma pessoa muito simples eu
tinha certa vergonha eu não tenho
vergonha de falar isso porque é ela sabe
disso porque é uma pessoa super humilde
supersimples uma fala muito muito
simples né eu queria algo muito maior
algo extraordinário uma mãe maravilhosa
minha mãe é tem 75 anos já não era muito
moça quando quando teve a mãe né
eu venho de uma família muito humilde
minha mãe teve seis filhos
eu sou a caçula a minha mãe era
analfabeta
ela é pernambucana ela é separada e ela
que criou os seus filhos
eu e meus irmãos sozinha nós
trabalhávamos como boia-fria alguém sabe
o que é isso
eu fui bateria eu colhi café e algodão
coli cana por tucanos
tive uma vida uma infância que as
pessoas falam assim nossa vida é muito
difícil para a criança que trabalha é
porque eu ia pra roça com 16 anos com
cinco anos com quatro anos né e aquilo
era uma grande diversão na verdade não
estou dizendo que eu sou a favor do
trabalho infantil por favor não me
entenda mal mas acho que algumas
responsabilidades elas devem ser
colocadas para as crianças poderem ter
uma noção do que é uma é do que é uma
vida adulta de responsabilidade com as
suas coisas seja com seu quarto ou seja
como não tem três filhos
eles na verdade eles que me ajudam nem
eu porque imagina cuidar de três filhos
a fazer tudo que eu faço né
hoje eu tenho um filho de 20 anos esse
menino aqui e se tem 15 esse é o robert
esse é o pedro henrique e esse é o vento
todos eles sem exceção têm um grande
prazer em me apresentar como mãe e não é
porque eu tenho uma prótese não porque
eu posso andar e falar e gesticular
porque eu não tinha próximo a dois anos
até dois anos
então é porque eu consegui me reinventar
a partir daquele momento
sabem com aquela situação eu me revestir
de mim mesma
quando eu saí do hospital eu saí em uma
cadeira de rodas
não sei só que aqui alguém já precisou
de uma cadeira de rodas
eu tive a impressão de que a moça ele
usa sim então eu sair eu não sei o que
foi que aconteceu com ela mas eu vou
contar como foi pra mim eu saí do
hospital
empurrada eu fiquei 22 dias no hospital
minha perna foi amputada cinco dias após
ao acidente foi um acidente
automobilístico mobilete não foi moto
poderia ser bicicleta poderia ser um
monte de coisa sair do hospital depois
de 22
debilitada eu sou magrela já né
eu fui magra sou magra no engodo posso
comer o que quiser buscou femininas sair
empurrado numa cadeira de rodas e aquela
impressão de que eu era menor
sabe de que eu não iria conseguir olhar
as pessoas ficando nos olhos
sabem mas não era porque eu estava na
cadeira de rodas ela porque mesmo eu
estando em pé
a minha cabeça estava baixo
isso foi o primeiro dia e logo em
seguida foi muito foi muito rápido na
minha recuperação psicológica
eu chorei naquele dia tive o luto e eu
tive o luto naquele dia porque logo em
seguida eu já fui é logo em seguida do
futebol fui pra casa fiquei me recuperei
fisicamente inclusive né
e eu já tirei para o mundo eu fui para
uma festa que eu gostaria de ir aí tem
outro detalhe os meninos que eu achei
que não ia querer namorar comigo e eu já
tinha pensado eles antes de perder a
perna e eles vieram tudo porque achava
que agora que eu era menos né
eles vinham pra me pediu em namoro é
porque agora eu só tinha uma perna então
eu iria aceitá los
ledo engano ledo engano todos foram
dispensados do mesmo jeito
bom então assim a foi tudo uma
construção e nós somos responsáveis
assim como nós somos responsáveis pela
cozinha brasileira como nós somos
responsáveis pelos nossos filhos como
somos responsáveis por melhorar e e
tirar o preconceito ou promover outras
pessoas a serem opção nós somos
responsáveis em por isso
isso chegou até nós então é da nossa
conta
isso aqui foi muito legal falar sobre
isso porque quando eu estava
olhando lá no mato grosso do sul que eu
morei lá durante muito tempo
uma amiga minha que ela tinha uma
pequena deformidade no pé no pé esquerdo
é essa minha amiga me disse que iria
fazer começar a fazer dança do ventre e
eu sou apaixonada por dança eu adoraria
ser bailarina dançarina alguma hino e aí
ela eu falei você acha que eu daria
conta eu tinha prótese na época né
acho que daria conta de dançar a dança
do ventre
não é muito difícil mesmo né
deve ser muito difícil mesmo aí depois
que nós viemos pra cá pra são paulo eu
fui até uma academia e aí eu cheguei e
fui lá ver as meninas dançando que toda
apaixonada só pessoa muito apaixonada
pela vida pelas coisas que eu gosto que
eu desejo para a minha vida e aí é eu
cheguei pra dona da academia
você acha que eu conseguiria é fazer
dança do ventre
pra mim quem vai me dizer se você como é
que você vai saber se você consegue
eu tenho uma perna só então tem gente
que tem duas e não dança e logo depois
eu dancei me apresentei foi muito legal
foi uma realização aqui nós estão só
estamos falando das minhas conquistas
que isso pra mim é um foi uma grande
conquista né
principalmente porque as pessoas elas
dizem pra você acha que determinam elas
querem tomar posse da sua vida toma
cuidado com isso porque às vezes as
pessoas que nos amam que querem tomar
posse na nossa vida e determinar o que
você deve ou não fazer
às vezes dentro de casa a gente é
sobrecarregado por afazeres domésticos
a e sendo que você sabe que você tem
outras coisas que também são importantes
e que você gostaria para sua vida não
presta bem atenção porque você é o dono
da sua vida e é você que vai ter de que
precisa determinar o que você deseja pra
ela e quem vai dizer pra você
se você pode ou não é você mesmo vai lá
e faz salto em distância
eu dançava sem prótese não tinha provas
pessoas de cadeira de rodas já vi
dançando com cadeira de rodas jordans
ando em sabemos desse contexto é só tem
distância eu sou recordista brasileira
no salto em distância é ainda sou
detentora do recorde brasileiro
alguém conhece salto em distância sabe
como é que faz
você tem que correr nunca no meu caso
saúde tá até a linha né
e se jogar para poder ver o quanto você
conseguiu
eu consegui pouco 2 e 47 mas muito por
ter uma perna só né
foi interessante porque nesse dia foi
diferente foi colocado assim a prova
porque eles aumentaram a distância sabe
e aí eu não tinha como poderia me
machucar e nesse dia foi um dia sim de
prova porque eu tive que ser a primeira
foi a primeira fazer e eu fiz e foi um
dia muito especial porque eu conseguir
passar por cima dos meus medos né e hoje
eu tenho o recorde brasileiro
a são silvestre eu corri na são
silvestre de muletas 15 quilômetros
logo em seguida foi às cataratas do
iguaçu que são 21 quilômetros também de
muleta em branco que nessa época eu não
tinha prótese
essa montanha que eu escalei essa que
está aqui atrás aqui
edinho letras também na verdade o meu
guia levou as muletas pra mim eu poderia
ter mais
leveza algumas campanhas contra o
preconceito campanha outro rumo à
conquista salto alto
acho que quando eu sofri o acidente eu
queria usar salto alto depois eu estava
nessa fase né
parece muito simples mas eu usava salto
de muletas e era fantástico e depois com
a prótese né
e aqui foi um um desfile que eu fiz por
um estilista fernando cosendey lá do rio
de janeiro que ele me encontrou próteses
eu já tenho quatro próteses
eu busquei fazer sempre o meu melhor que
eu tinha uma pessoa uma mulher pobre com
deficiência três filhos eu sou separada
eu cuido dos meus filhos sozinha neto
tudo pra dar errado tudo pra não vencer
né
mas quando a gente toma posse da nossa
vida a gente vai lá e faz
é faz apenas três anos que eu faço parte
da seleção paraolímpica de vela
tudo isso porque eu trilhei um caminho
porque a nossa vida ela aparece em
certos momentos assim como o microfone
parou de funcionar
algumas coisas param de funcionar ea
gente não sabe o que fazer com isso a
gente precisa se reinventar encontrar o
seu sonho o seu novo sonho e com certeza
quando você encontrar você tomar posse
disso você vai fazer da sua vida algo
muito mais espectacular do que ela
poderia ter sido tomar posse